لم يتاهل المنتخب العراقي الى تصفيات كاس
العالم لعام 2022 المقام حاليا بدوله قطر
لكن العراق ساهم في هذا الحدث الذي يشارك
فيه 32 منتخبا من مختلف قارات العالم
دعونا نرى كيف كانت هذه المشاركه
[موسيقى]
ملعب استاد الجنوب احد السادات الثمانيه
المستضيفه لهذه البطوله والذي افتتح في
ايار مايو عام 2019 من تصميم المعماريه
العراقيه زها حديد وهو مستوحه من التاريخ
البحري لمدينه الوكره بعد ان درس الحديد
مع عالم المنطقه وتاريخها ويتسع هذا
الملعب ل 40 الف مشجع
[موسيقى]
شاركت العراقيه رحمه رياض الغنائي
للمونديال اغنيه قناديل السمالي كاتبتها
المغربيه منال شاركت فيها المغنيه
المغربيه الكنديه نوره فتحي والاماراتيه
بلقيس اضافه الى رحمه اعلن الاتحاد الدولي
لكره القدم عن اطلاق هذه الاغنيه عبر
حسابه في تويتر
[موسيقى]
القمصان التي شارك فيها المنتخب القطري في
البطوله كانت من تصميم العراقي حماده
الداودي القميص حافظ على لونه العنابي مع
اضافه اشكال هندسيه تعكس الشكل الخارجي
لبعض الملاعب البطوله اضافه بقميص ثان
باللون الابيض تظهر فيها الاشكال الهندسيه
بحجم اكبر وباللون الذهبي الخفيف
[موسيقى]
واخيرا عن ملتقي كاس العالم الرسمي فقد
كلفت قطر النحات العراقيه العالمي احمد
البحراني بتحويل الملصق الى عمل النحتيه
سي يوضع في ساحه ستادلو حيث ستقام
المباراه النهائيه للمونديال
[موسيقى]